this is a production of Cornell
University
so I the title in my talk is giving
Second Life to long-term accuracy
ecosystem experiments and somebody has
requested that I guess I should
enable it all right
um but that's actually a fairly small
piece of my talk uh I should come clean
and say the real reason that I'm going
to my talk is uh see sorry my Zoom thing
is in the way of my presenter notes
which
makes it hard to see there we go
um I gave it away because I clicked
um
so I worked with Lori drinkwater as a
postdoc from 2019 to 2021 and during the
last few months of that process I
started my new position full time with
the USDA ARS so there's still a lot to
finish from my postdoc work and my new
position happens to be remote and I have
personal reasons to stay in Ithaca for
the next couple of years so Lori
suggests that I seek out courtesy
faculty position in Horticulture the
first step of which is to give a
departmental seminar so I signed up for
one
um so I wanted to give you guys a little
pitch about what I could offer as a
courtesy faculty member in Horticulture
so first of all teaching uh my alma
mater the University of Minnesota where
I did my PhD has a really good
Department of teaching biology and
learning I took a lot of classes in that
department I taught worked as a TA for I
lost count of how many semesters because
you know EEB programs there's not a lot
of funding
um I've also done some guest teaching
for Lori and she's offered me
opportunities to continue guest teaching
in her class and I've also talked to
Sarah Wright one of the data Librarians
about possibly co-teaching a class on
data management for graduate students
that I don't think that's going to be
possible this spring but a possibility
for next spring
if we can talk to the right people and
get it to work so um
I also have a lot to offer in terms of
collaborative research there's my
ongoing work in Laura's lab I also have
a lot of I don't want to say Loose Ends
but
um additional research products from my
postdoc work with liking cover crops
that's related to Jenny Moore's work
with the cover crop breeding project so
there's
continued opportunities for
collaboration there and then finally I
can provide additional student support
so I have mentored and supervise at
least 16 probably more undergrads since
I was a grad student and Lori's lab has
two new grad students this semester and
I've been attending lab meetings and can
offer some additional support there I
also am currently supervising undergrads
through internships in the USDA
including one Cornell student and there
may be additional opportunities there
so I'm gonna
go for my research outline now so I'm
going to start by summarizing my
research background and then going into
my current role as data manager for the
drives project which I will explain what
drives me soon
and then
um hopefully
imbue some well-one wisdom about data
management from this process of
integrating long-term experiments so my
uh research background kind of the core
of it is evolutionary ecology for my
Master's I looked at plant insect
interactions in the prairie and I was
really interested in how species
interactions Drive evolutionary
processes and vice versa and really
thinking about population and Community
scale questions
and this theme of evolutionary ecology
continued into my PhD research at the
University of Minnesota where I worked
with for Denison on legume and symbiotic
nitrogen fixation
and those were more kind of abstract
questions about conflicts of interest
between plants and their symbiotic
bacteria over how they allocate
resources
and it also ended up turning into have a
more abstract
project about life history of symbiotic
rhizobia how selection in and out of the
host affects traits that affect how
beneficial the rhizobia are to the
legumes and it was all very
yeah abstract I keep using that word uh
but for postdoc research I stuck with
symbiotic nitrogen fixation but I
stepped a little bit more into the real
world of agriculture in Lori's lab and I
joined to work with the cover crop
breeding project that was a
collaboration with Lori's lab Matt Ryan
um to USDA folks and that's still
ongoing and of course we're still
publishing stuff the main focus was on
um Harry vetch as a model cover crop so
my work was really
um looking into the
um functional and fixation traits and
trying to identify interesting trait
differences that readers could perhaps
select for but working with Lori has
given me much more
um of a background in ecosystem ecology
specifically soil biogeochemistry
nutrient cycling and you know the the
soil piece that I was missing before
when I was just focusing on the plant
the microbe
and so I've used a lot of different
approaches throughout my research career
a lot of field experiments and
Greenhouse experiments and then work
like you know growth Chambers with where
gas exchange measurements and lots of
little wires sticking out everywhere
microbiology work uh but a big part of
my background has also just been in
learning a lot about statistics
especially using Bayesian methods and um
a big part of my PhD dissertation was uh
using mathematical modeling to help
interpret experimental results and
um deepen hypotheses and right now I'm
really interested in the interface
between process-based modeling and
statistical modeling so for example
using a process-based model to generate
a null hypothesis then testing that with
a statistical model
um and of course data management is part
of everybody's research but that's
really the piece that got me my current
gig with the USDA so the drives project
we now have a very nice logo uh it
stands for diverse rotations improve
valuable ecosystem Services they spent a
lot of time coming up with that acronym
and I think it's very very fitting
so a little bit of History
um it started back in 2018 with a
workshop called corn in context let by
Matt Liebman and they came up with some
ideas about how important it is to
there's all these long-term experiments
that have relevant data sets and so
wouldn't it be great if we could put all
these experiments together and just do a
really big study about how cropping
system diversity impacts system level
performance yield stability and not just
look at yields but look at the soil and
wouldn't that be great and then uh like
hey there's there's a grant due in like
two weeks let's write it and they did
and they got it so there's a nifa
program called networks for synthesis
data sharing and management and they
managed to get some funding they uh hire
a postdoc which is my good friend and
Bobby Finley who I'm sure many of you
know recent Cornell graduate
and we've got a really good team of
people plus some interns and uh it's
been I've been working the project for
about a year and actually Ann gave a
seminar about it a few months before I
joined so
this will be a bit of an update if any
of you saw that
so the core objectives of the drives
project are first to build a network of
long-term cropping experiments and by
Network I really mean two things there's
the network of data the drives database
which is really my role but there's also
the network of people so we have
bi-monthly collaborator meetings we're
just basically trying to help people who
do similar things meet each other and
connect and hope that stuff comes from
that
and the second objective is to actually
use that wonderful data resource to do
some research so we are working on a
paper to quantify yield stability and
resilience to extreme weather as a
function of rotational diversity and
what's Innovative about you know other
people have done similar things but
what's really Innovative about what
we're doing is we're actually looking at
yield at the whole rotation level not
just at the crop level and I can say as
somebody who's actually put now put that
data set together there's a reason that
nobody's looked at data a yield on the
whole rotation level it's it's a
nightmare but we're crazy so we're doing
it is this corn only oh good question
yeah it started with corn and that was
the first thing was like okay we're just
gonna have something that every
everybody has corn and then it's corn
and something else but now we're like
well there's a lot of Wheat and small
grain systems we'll we'll put those in
there too and so most of our sites are
Corn based it's a lot of stuff in the
midwest but we're growing we're adding
more sites and so we're yeah growing
Beyond corn
but uh one of the main
applications for This research hopefully
will be improving risk assessment for
crop insurance which I don't know a lot
of details about it now but all I know
is that the incentives for using more
complex rotations are really
or rather crop insurance is an incentive
against using more complex rotation
because it really favors good yields now
and a lot of the complexity benefits
arise over time so hopefully we can help
improve those calculations
and uh we also hope to do some research
into the biophysical mechanisms of how
diverse rotations influence yield and so
forth we're working on collecting for
the data the data for that so for
example carbon sequestration
um and that's soil moisture data we're
working with a soil model uh modeler
we'll see that's kind of the
new part
so um so far we have data from 20 sites
throughout North America the furthest
North is up in actually it's funny I
think of it as being Canada but it's
technically Minnesota another look at
this map but we have some sites in
Canada we have a few sites down in
Mexico that are part of the um the
cement
program
and uh the requirements for joining was
that there have to be at least three
full rotation cycles of data so I think
the most recent experiment is like eight
years and the longest is
like 60 years and then there have to be
at least two rotations with contrasting
diversity so there's some long-term
sites where it's like it's all corn
soybean but we're only looking at
tillage it's like that's great but it's
not for us
um so drives is not the only data
networking effort out there we have a
lot of uh connections with other
networks that are happening and we
started out
um planning to be a hub of the AG cross
database is there anything ever heard of
that
sort of a
sort of a new thing um
and that is basically connecting
you know the long-term agricultural
research Network ltar which maybe more
people have heard of there's there's all
these like data Gathering efforts but
they all have sort of different goals
and and we figure rather than trying to
put everything in one place it's like
let's just make it so it all connects so
we've um I've been working with people
at the soil Health Institute to because
a lot of our participating sites have
like they gave some data to them so they
gave it to us and then we're also
connecting with this gl10 network which
is based in the UK but and is more
focused on European and
um like African long-term studies but
we're um trying to plug into all these
existing resources so we don't have to
reinvent the wheel
so I just want to go a little bit into
the process of building the drafts
database so the first step is we met
individually with every site over Zoom
because that's the area we live in and
just um try to do our homework
collecting information
establishing agreements because you know
you got to make sure you're not stepping
on anyone's toes agreeing when to
publish et cetera and then they
get their data as neat and tidy as they
can and they give it to us and so the
first year it's mainly just getting the
details of the experiments crop yields
weather data and then now we're working
on Gathering additional management data
such as planting Harvest dates soils
data
um so this process is a lot easier for
some sites than others if they've
already participated in a Data Network
then it's like oh yeah we put it all
together in the this data entry template
I'll just send you that and it's it's
great it's well documented at other
sites it's like oh
um I think there's a hard drive
somewhere that has the 2010 data and I
think a graduate student took it 10
years ago I I think I still have their
email so it's it's very varied but
they've done an amazing job at getting
us what they can and there's some stuff
especially these long-term experiments
that if it's not there it doesn't exist
anymore which is sad
um and then of course what I do is I
take their beautifully packaged data and
I stick it through my meat grinder and
just uh do some quality control
so uh two strategies that I highly
recommend for data quality control are
making a template so basically I know
what data is supposed to be there and
then I can see what date is there and
then what's supposed to fit in there and
doesn't and I've actually found quite a
few like you know oh I marked the wrong
plots that year it's like mistakes that
the sites didn't catch and then of
course just the simple thing of graphing
it you know it's like oh why is this
Alfalfa yield a thousand times higher
than the other ones oh it looks like
they added an extra digit like yeah a
lot of stuff that's hard that's easy to
catch but hard to catch
and then of course configuring it for
the drive's database
which uh I just a trigger warning I'm
going to show a diagram that's really
complicated
okay there it is
um
I'm not going to explain this whole
diagram but I just wanted to show here
is the database schema uh and each of
these represents a different table
right now I actually have I say database
because it is but it's not in like you
know SQL or a database management system
right now because that's
harder with I I don't won't get into
like what when that's a good workflow
and when it isn't but for expedience
sake right now I have everything in a
set of Google Sheets and building some
of these interdependencies with data
validation and so forth and
um you know everything with the color is
explains something that's referred to in
another table but anyway
um separate information Separate Tables
so and I don't show here there's we also
have extensive data dictionary and
um workflow stuff so just a lot of
things
um I just wanted to share a few design
principles that have been really helpful
for this challenge of putting all these
experiments with different designs
together and dealing with changes in
experimental design over time because
somebody comes in and they're like why
are we looking at continuous corn we
should be looking at like corn mung bean
it's like okay let's get rid of the
continuous foreign actually I can say
that nobody gets rid of continuous porn
but you know what I mean
um so here's an example of someone is is
the concept of vertical design so this
is an example of horizontal design so
let's say I want to say what
experimental treatments were applied to
each plot so I have like when that
happened and then I have like a column
for each different kind of treatment and
so as you add more sites you have to add
more columns because you know other
sites might have like a manure versus no
manure or they might have like you know
we played music to it or we didn't play
music to it like that you know you want
to account for everything and so the
more sites you have the more cumbersome
your table gets uh but with vertical
design you don't necessarily have to
plan ahead of time you just have
you know whatever the treatment type is
whatever the treatment level is and then
you know if there's different timings
for different treatments I can you know
I'm not constrained so um kind of apply
that
where possible just for the maximum
flexibility
um another strategy I really like is
this concept of the database view that's
raise your hand if you've heard of that
it's something I learned about fairly
recently and a concept I'm applying
fairly Loosely but the analogy I think
about is your database is kind of like
your pantry it's where you store your
data you label all your ingredients your
packaging has all your nutritional
information like you know what goes into
it and then you have some kind of recipe
let's say a script where you merge
things together you filter out the data
you don't want you do calculations Etc
and then what you're left with is you
know the actual pie and what you're
actually using but you're not really you
know
to actually do your analysis you end up
with usually some kind of monster table
that just has everything
um in a real database what they do is
this table shows up but there's no data
actually stored there it's sort of just
a way of looking at the outcome of a set
of merge functions and filters and blah
blah blah
um which I don't do that the proper way
but I have like okay here's my database
here's my script here's my data view
which I'm going to save somewhere else
use this for the analysis but if I'm
going to share my database with anybody
you know the database is the way to go
it's so much easier to have all your
documentation quality control and then
this is kind of like a temporary object
that's just for used
um and of course this whole process I
use scripts for everything mostly are a
little bit of python but the advantage
of that is we can do collaborative
coding with our GitHub repository and if
I need to go back and change something I
can you know make a little edit to the
script and just run it again
um
but of course you know
it's really hard to manage data for a
multi-year experiment and
funding Cycles are short people leave
people die
um and then what you're left with is
a lot of stuff
so I I want to shift gears a little bit
and uh I shouldn't check my watch
because it's wrong but
um
okay talk a little bit about some
strategy lessons for data management
so here's kind of the ideal workflow
it's what we say we do in our papers we
design our experiment we collect our
data process it we analyze it and
publish it and then we you know pop a
champagne and
and you know this whole process
results in a bunch of stuff which I
consider all of this to be data right so
when you design your experiment you're
going to write up a set of protocols
that you're going to use in the field or
in the lab or what have you you have
your Rod primary data and whatever files
you use to to process it and then you
have
edited data that you analyze and maybe a
whole bunch of different files that go
into your manuscript and and we all are
accustomed to keeping track of all these
different things
um and it's hard enough in this
idealized form but in the real world you
know let's say In a multi-year
experiment you might have the first year
where you're doing all the things and
then in year two you're still collecting
more data from year one and meanwhile
you've had to you've done some
preliminary analysis or buys your
protocols you have more data and you
have more edited data and the different
stages of development and then you go
another year and you're still processing
data from year one and two and maybe
you've got a different set of protocols
and you know you've you can't ideally
you want to do the same thing every year
but you know by year four your funding's
running out so you've got to apply for
another Grant and you're still catching
up on old projects and and time goes by
and and people leave and maybe someday
in the future you or not you or maybe uh
now it's future you who forgot about
past you whoever it is they're stuck
with this mess that you or or passed you
or the version of past you made and
you're like they're like what do I do
um
so
basically it's kind of like it's kind of
like being fit
the solutions are simple we all know
what to do but it's hard to do it in the
moment
so a good analogy of Fitness is that the
best exercise is whatever you're able to
do consistently so I have to design a
system that's easy enough to stick with
in the hardest of times but also you
know you have to account for those
unknown unknowns so you have to have
enough flexibility to accommodate change
so I think the best
and most important data management habit
is to document as you go I call this the
Memento principle anyone seen that that
movie it's a guy who has short-term
memory loss and can't remember has to
like write all these cryptic messages
for himself so he remembers who's out to
get him and who's not and it's very
suspenseful
um but there's a lot of uh strategies
for documentation that kind of allow for
real life so I'm a fan of the stream of
Consciousness research log
um I haven't gone it's not in my pocket
is it
um having note-taking software on your
phone where you have like the date and
you can use like your phone's voice
transcription software so if you're just
too tired to write you can at least get
something
um
make every time I make a table or a file
I make something that explains what it
is for the drive stuff I have like one
Central you know table dictionary column
dictionary but when it's you know more
in the early stages of a research
project I might just make like you know
a tab or another file that's like okay
here's what all these column means or if
I make really descriptive file names and
column names I don't have to do as much
documentation
um photos are also really good strategy
they're time stamped especially if you
have some way of backing them up and
I've actually known people who use
Twitter as a research documentation tool
just like take a picture we went out and
surveyed plot 30 today and it's on the
Internet it's time stamped it's
organized I mean Twitter owns it but
it's a very boring Twitter profile but
other than that I think it's a good
strategy
um
another system I like thinking of is the
touch at once principle which I learned
from my grandmother but it's kind of
like uh you know when I come in the door
I use my keys I step in the door I put
my keys on the hook if I put my keys
down and then to put on the hook I need
to touch it again it's probably I'm
probably just not going to be able to
find them later
um so basically setting up your system
to minimize the number of steps you need
to you know make your documentation
useful or have your files accessible by
other people and a lot of this these
days is Technical Solutions I'm sure
plenty of you have strategies you use
um and finally a strategy that I found
really useful I credit to Brian Carlson
who's a data manager for the LTR network
but it's this concept of uh data zones
and I mean this sort of an abstract
sense like the zone is uh partially a
location but it could also be a way you
name things but you um basically your
raw zone is everything primary so
obviously your raw data the protocols
that apply to that data I also consider
correspondence
um I really like saving emails as PDFs
in with whatever thing they apply to any
field notes and then your working zone
is a little bit more amorphous it's
anything that's in progress you know
intermediate data sets and then once you
get to the point of say submitting a
manuscript you've got your production
Zone which is like whatever final super
super final I really mean at this time
dot you know CSV file that's your final
edited data set you have whatever files
or like what you submitted to the
journal and usually like you know while
you're working on things that's whatever
is the most recent iteration
uh so the main thing that's really
important uh for the sake of your
documentation is once you're finished
nobody cares about this that's for you
what's really important is being able to
trace this path between the raw and
production
because uh that's what transparent
reproducible research is all about
so um when I'm you know making
documentation I really focus my effort
especially in the Raw data that's you
know the stuff as you go in the
production data if I've got really good
documentation of my raw data it makes
that step a lot easier
um so in that sense it's like having a
clear version of what every file is
using stable file format so
um
text-based files like csvs PDFs or you
know things that aren't going to be
corrupted by some software change
um and you know every file is
essentially organized but then in your
working Zone you know you have enough
have to have enough documentation so you
know what's going on and you're going to
have stuff at different stages uh one
Version Control technique I find really
easy to do and useful is putting the
date and file name specifically with
this format it sorts just everybody
should just be in the habit of writing
their dates with in that order
um that's my soapbox
and then um you know it's uh stuff
that's expendable
but you know it's
it's hard it's hard to keep everything
separate but the idea is if I want to be
able to look back in what I did it's
like okay I know I know where I started
I know where I'm ending up and then um
everything in the middle is going to be
messy and that's okay
so that's actually
I or where I can end
um but I want to thank my colleagues who
helped me prepare for today and Lori for
suggesting that I do this in the seminar
organizers and the people in Zoom have
been being so patient
thank you I'm gonna open up to any any
questions or you know if you want to
share uh the technique that's worked for
you or a challenge and data management I
think we've got time
yes so uh once you have all the data
organized in your database what kind of
analytical tools you foresee using to be
a pretty huge data set
I mean basically uh yeah so our analysis
is uh well it's funny because it seems
like a huge data set but in the
um world of data science it's actually
pretty small data set right because
um you know people who do like
bioinformatics or you know marketing
research they're dealing with like
gigabytes of data this is like
maybe the whole thing might be one gig
um but we use um so we're using Bayesian
models in R primarily so I've spent poll
of the last like two months making a uh
very complex data view for we have two
sets of models one for looking at focal
crops and effects of diversity and one
for looking at rotation level and both
of those have different criteria for
what data should be included and
excluded and for the rotation level
you've gotta
impute some missing phases or be able to
see what's missing so that's actually
really the hardest part and then but
then once we have the data set it's like
okay let's uh we've got the um both the
berms and the rethinking package in R
we've got some uh some Bayesian models
kind of set up they take a really long
time to run
um so we use um you could do it on your
personal computer I often use the uh the
USDA supercomputer just because it's
faster and less likely to crash
um but it's you know fairly manageable
once
you get it all together
question about the horizontal versus
vertical I forget the exactly oh yes I
kind of made it up but I think it's a
thing all right and so my question is
with the horizontal design
um
for me that's that's what I intuitively
use and for that it's very easy to just
like feed that into R and then it's like
each column is a thing that you can test
whereas the vertical design that seems
like that would be a bit harder to do
have you worked with oh yeah that's a
good question actually so this comes
back to the issue of your data storage
versus your data View so like this is
the easiest way to build and add data
but when I'm actually analyzing it I
heard it back to horizontal right I use
um usually like the reshape function I
know there's tidy verse things but I
kind of uh I'm new to tidy verse
um so what I end up with in my really
extensive data view is like a gazillion
columns with each possible treatment
type across all of everything and so
it's like it's fairly easy to go back
and forth between these things but
um when you're collecting and storing
data
um having the vertical design has some
advantages
but yeah most of the sites since they
just have like you know let's say if
they just have a tillage and a fertility
treatment like it makes sense for them
to have those columns but for our
purposes it's like well some people have
a village treatment and some people you
know have much more creative treatment
so yeah it's uh
helpful
um
how are you working statistically around
the holes in the long-term data sets yes
um so the first step I have on my
computer I have like a gazillion
thoughts about this this has been like
I'm glad you asked that because that's
been like my life for like the past two
months
um
the it depends on how big the hole is
um so it's setting some criteria like
um so uh one is in the experimental
design is every phase of rotation there
every year in theory so like there's
some uh
rotations that we just had to take out
because it's like they just had two
entry phases of a six year rotation and
so for the rotation level yield you need
to have the same crops there every year
or else that number is going to mean
something different oh I should also say
uh I barely the lead there we're
converting it to yield dollars using uh
National agricultural statistics price
data which I don't think is going to be
that different than the raw yields but
it's it's a big selling point but anyway
so gaps
um so one solution is to just take out
the whole thing if it's big enough
another solution is um
So within that experimental design are
there other replicates of that same
treatment phase that are there like is
it just one plot that got missed for
example and if that's the case I'll take
the average from the corresponding
replicates and fill it in for that
missing one
but then if the whole thing is missing
it's uh you know how much of the is it
the whole rotation is it like how much
the rotation is it and uh what I usually
do is
um you kind of have to go side by side
to see if it's suitable but for most of
them I would use a a gam you know some
sort of smoothing function of that
specific crop and treatment over time
and then see like okay does that seem
like a suitable you know estimate and
the reason I do that in the rotation
level and not in the yield level is you
know let's say you've got five different
crops but you're just missing one of
them in like you know three years
um and it might be a different one
um so that missing one you just want to
put a plausible value as a placeholder
but the other four crops are really
going to provide informative data and
you don't want to lose that and
especially with a lot of these if we
just took out all the years with a
missing phase we wouldn't have much left
so yeah a combination of just
going site by sight and imputing things
I also have have a lot of things I
originally I was like I'm going to talk
about all the annoying excelled things
that people send me that people
shouldn't do and I was like that'll be
too pedantic but but I could get into
some of that yeah
so
um
a big part of it is uh
thinking about what what a computer can
understand and what a person can
understand so I've gotten data sets
where
um you know they use colors to indicate
these are the years where there was
something wrong
and uh or like they have you know notes
that are they use some kind of special
formatting and like when you're a person
looking at it like oh that's great I can
see that that and that but when you're
trying to
put it into a computer just I have to
just code all that and it's really
annoying so
um
part of you know the touch of one's
principle saving time is trying to
collect your data to the extent you can
in a way that a computer can understand
so you can automate things so a computer
understands uh strings
uh well there's the type of data so you
know character numeric
um and then for subcategories of numeric
like integer um you know Boolean oh yeah
oh yeah logical I think those are the
three main Things Are character numeric
and logical and then dates are kind of
their own saying um do you have them as
much as in the character category as you
can you'll be better off
um
so kind of trying to keep things in
those four categories
um so for example
um having just one type of data per
column so something I see really
commonly is like they'll be like okay
here's the yield and then when there's
missing they'll just say like Oh missing
this year in the same column and then
you know sometimes they might have like
a DOT
um so when that's read into a computer
it's just interpreting everything as a
character string but I really want it to
be a number so
um it's like if I have notes make sure
that's in a different column it's all
character stuff
um
yeah I think things like really simple
things like that oh and not hiding any
information that's useful in Excel
formulas
um so I've had
um a real doozy of a time figuring out
unit conversions for bushels to
basically you know the volume based
things to weight-based things
um bushels per acre or just like the
bane of my existence because every crop
has a different conversion between
bushels and yield and it depends what
their standard moisture level is which
can kind of vary from place to place
even though everybody says oh yeah
standard moisture like well yeah but
those were there it's 12 and over here
it's 14 like
um I know it doesn't make that much of a
difference but I've figured out a lot of
these things like I was only able to
figure it out because it was hidden in
some Excel formula somewhere and uh
you know it's um so having
uh any calculations be transparent so if
there's a column that's calculated from
other columns having those other columns
there even if it seems really even if
it's the same thing in every column
because at least that's you know
transparent documentation although I I
prefer to do any kind of you know
calculation of one thing from other
things in a script rather than in a
Excel sheet there's although there's
also this tool called um open refine
which is a good intermediate for between
for people who want to have like a
reproducible data cleaning but don't
want to learn scripting
um it's completely open access it's more
of an interface kind of like Excel but
then it saves everything you do in like
this thing or like a set of steps in the
background and if you want to do the
same thing again you can just run all
those steps so um it's like a little bit
of a probably less of a learning curve
than you know using learning R but uh
it's a good um option
see trying to think of other things oh
um
thinking about how to how to design
to translate between machines and humans
so
um sometimes you need to design for
humans like I had to enter all this
information from a map image and it was
the best way to do it was just to make a
data sheet that was shaped like the map
and you know maybe even going out in the
field it's like you have you know
something that's organized in a way
that's least error prone and easy to do
but then you know I have a set of rows
and columns computers are good at
positions you know if you have a matrix
you can have rows and columns or if you
have a set of tables like you know as
long as you know it's the same position
then I can relate that to another thing
and put it into you know a nice neat
table but if I'm trying to use that nice
neat table when I'm entering information
I'm going to be like okay where's plot
101 and oh shoot that was plot 110 and
there's more mistakes to be made
so uh yeah I've been wants to you know
look at some fun stuff I'm always happy
to do that
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu